compliance audits can be arduous
painstaking
time-consuming tasks let's see how
policy controllers simplified oma's job
enough for her to leave work before
dinner time on an audit day
it's audit day and as people responsible
for performing audits know
this is a time every month when oma
feels overwhelmed because she needs to
review whether the entire company's
infrastructure
is compliant this typically involves
many
hours of reviewing configurations
meetings with team leads
and analyzing running infrastructure to
make sure everything is compliant
a lot of the time spent tracking down
potential problems would disappear
if there is a way to automatically
enforce correct policy
instead of having to track down possible
compliance issues
it would be better to have a system that
stopped them from occurring in the first
place
omar heard a lot about the new tools
that charlie's team introduced
and is wondering if those tools can
possibly help them
after hearing their issues charlie
explains policy controller and how it
can
not only ensure compliance but also
enable audit logging
of violations that were uncovered when
policies were introduced
oma is intrigued to say the least policy
controller is a kubernetes dynamic
admission controller
that checks audits and enforces your
cluster compliance
with policies related to security
regulations
or arbitrary business rules policy
controller
enforces cluster compliance with
policies called constraints
constraints are a powerful feature that
allow for fine-grained control
over a cluster for example you can
enforce many of the same requirements as
pod security policies but with the added
ability to audit your configurations
before enforcing it
you can limit the type of volumes that
can be mounted to pods
or even control the repository a given
container image can be pulled from
and more along with constraints policy
controller also introduces constraint
templates
these allow you to define how a
constraint works but delegate defining
the specifics of the constraints to an
individual
or group with subject matter expertise
in addition to separating concerns this
also separates the logic of the
constraints
from its definition so for example if
you have a family of applications that
will have to use a limited range of
ports you can define a template like
this
to limit the range but define that range
with a constraint at implementation time
oma's team decides to start requiring
labels on namespace
that specify who the namespace owner is
this is a good use
of the k8 required labels constraints
in order to start using policy
controller to add a required label
oma first creates a corresponding
constraint with the dry run mode set
this allows oma to monitor all the
violations without causing downtime
once this constraint is applied to the
cluster oma can view the audit by
looking at the constraint object logs
she now has a list of teams and services
to talk to
after they fix the issues she removes
the enforcement action
which means the default enforcement
actions deny takes effect to even stop
further policy violations from occurring
in the past she used to have to follow
up with teams individually to
retroactively track down and fix policy
violations
now with policy controller oma has a
list of violations and a way to block
them from occurring
policy controller using a familiar get
ops approach to enable policy rules for
existing configs
and logs violations that do occur once
enabled
and best of all because of policy
controller oma got to be home before
dinner on an audit day for the first
time ever
so that's it for policy controller make
sure to check out the description for
links to more resources on it
and like and subscribe to the channel
for more videos about google cloud
thanks for watching
you